it's a long time isn't it
i mean all the evidence was there when
the war came down in 1989 um our
president of the time and the ioc just
that really did not want to face this
horrible period of time where they
allowed this to happen because there
were always two types of victims there
were people like myself that you know
didn't win medals that maybe they should
have done um and there were those east
german athletes those young girls that
were given terrible drugs throughout
puberty which has terrible long-term
side effects and many of them are
ill-known in fact some of them have even
died so this is a horrible period of
history which at long last our new
president of fina has decided to to look
into to apologize for and hopefully to
to make some some you know some some
compensation for
i mean pedro schneider's you know spoken
about it and and you you've met her and
and seen her but at the time were you
aware this was going on yes absolutely
100 you know this isn't something which
was happening we were going oh aren't we
surprised that 11 of the 13 gold medals
at the moscow olympic games went to east
german athletes in the women's races but
not a single man won a medal i mean it
was very very obvious they had young
girls that would appear on international
scenes we'd never seen them as a junior
we'd never heard of them before and they
were just smash world records they
looked and sounded very masculine they
had very big masculine developments um
you know and they were incredibly
successful only in the women's races
it was just so frustrating my dad would
often speak about it he was my coach at
the time
and because he would speak about it he
was never selected as an international
coach even though he had the most number
of medalists on that particular team so
it was very frustrating um you know i i
won a silver medal so people know who i
am but there were british peoples that
were fourth behind three east germans
and nobody knows their name and that's
very very wrong
because they should have had a gold as
well obviously i mean what would it what
difference would it have made to you
having your gold and not a silver
um if there's a big difference isn't
there between being an olympics of
adolescent being an olympic champion um
it would have been lovely you know at
times it would great if i was away at
the olympics i remember
when becky amazingly won her two golds
in beijing back in 2008 and everyone was
very excited and they constantly
referred to the last time a british girl
won a medal which was in the 60s you
know won a championships and that was
hard to deal with when we knew
categorically what was going on you know
we had all the stasi evidence we knew
exactly what they were taking when they
were taking it
so i think
i'm the last person to say that i want
anyone to turn up on anyone's door and
take their medals away i think what
should happen now is that the record
books should be changed and that new
medals maybe should be issued but
those girls were also victims of the
system and that needs to be acknowledged
and it never needs to happen again
and looking at the reasons why why it
was happening or why why it wasn't
tackled i mean it wasn't just because
people didn't want to go back to those
cold war times and it was something that
happened in the past and they just
didn't want to talk about it or was it
something do you think fundamentally
wrong with the governing body of
swimming
um not just swimming you know it wasn't
just something swimming was one of the
worst sports affected but also it
happened a lot in track and field it
happened in rowing you know the great
kathy cook was one of the most amazing
british athletes ever um she held the
400 meter record up until recently when
christina horague beat it and yet most
people again do not know who kathy cook
is so it's by far not just a swimming
problem but i'm very proud that fina the
swimming body now are the first to
actually say we want to do syria
something serious about this it was
endemic
they had east german doctors sitting on
the international ilc olympic doping
panel which is ridiculous and in fact
they even have awards still in place for
people that were given a criminal record
after the war came down who forced these
young girls to take these terrible drugs
so something has to be done to remove
those people and acknowledge what
actually happened
you talked about the girls and the
terrible legacy it has had on them um
how are many of them managing because i
i imagine that you you still have
contact with with these people that you
spent time with when you were younger
yeah not too much contact a little bit i
did a documentary um in 1990 when i met
petra um she was quite poorly then she
was only quite young i remember i took
my little girl with me who was three
months old and that was great and she's
now 23
and she got very upset because she
couldn't have any more children and she
was already on heart pills in fact we've
seen a few of the east german females
actually die since then so you know it's
it was very dire what actually happened
and i'm hoping that finna will will
clear the whole house up you know we've
unfortunately had a president in place
who wasn't always looking at putting the
athletes first and center which is
what's most important it was often about
what's the best hotel they can stay in
how much money can the association make
and sport has to be about the athletes
and it would be really wonderful to see
that this has been sorted out and it
would give the right message that
cheating with drugs or any form of
cheating is not to be accepted and when
they find out they will do something
about it
in terms of the people that were
affected it was as you say it was the
the women that um
took these drugs and they were the ones
that that had all of these successes why
do you think
is there any elements of sexism to that
that it that it was seen that the women
could be
meddled with as it were um or do you
think it just was simply the case that
the drugs available for the male
athletes just just weren't as readily
available or perhaps weren't as
effective
no no it wasn't that it wasn't readily
available the male athletes were also
given you know additional testosterone
it's just if you put a young girl on
testosterone through puberty you can
make a huge difference so the difference
between male and female performance at
international level ranges from about 10
to 30 so something like middle distance
running is 10
and something like weight lifting is
over 30 which is absolutely huge so if
you take
um 10 away from the girl that beat me
that was 16 seconds she'd been behind me
that wouldn't even put her in the final
so it meant that they could take very
average female athletes and give them
male testosterone through puberty and
make an absolutely huge difference so
they could dominate on the women's
racing scene but it would make very
little difference to the men maybe they
could you know improve them by by one
percent or even two percent at the most
but then a very good male athlete would
still be an east german male athlete
whereas with the women we could not make
up 10 15 20 it was impossible
what about the sport now
how clean is it do you think
um sport is always fighting this battle
you know this battle is never going to
go away because sport like life you know
people will try to cheat the system and
when money is involved and success is
involved and of course people are going
to try to be
the message that we have to give them is
that we're not going to tolerate it
we're going to find this better ways all
the time to catch cheats
we're going to find bigger deterrents i
would like to see
bands come into place and then you know
if you've caught a second time that's it
you're trying to cheat the system again
and you've not learned your lesson so i
think we need to have better deterrence
in place and obviously we are holding
samples now and post-testing and then
you know reiterating and reallocating
medals you can never give someone back
their moment you know you you we can't
you know there was a fantastic summer
colanoscopy she was fourth in 100 meters
at the 1980 olympic games you do not
know her name and her whole life would
have probably been different if she'd
been olympic champion we're never going
to be able to give that back to anne but
if we can at least acknowledge her and
put those updated results in the books
it's better late than never